el Papa Francisco presidió la misa de
pascua aquí en la plaza de San Pedro en
el Vaticano este domingo una celebración
que este año generaba particular interés
ya que la semana pasada Francisco estuvo
hospitalizado con bronquitis ante una
multitud de 100.000 personas el papa
pronunció la tradicional bendición Urbi
e Urbi a la ciudad y al mundo durante la
cual Francisco lamentó los conflictos
que sacuden el planeta invocó la
reconciliación la pacificación el
diálogo entre pueblos evocó en la guerra
en Ucrania hizo un llamado a la
comunidad internacional para obrar en
favor del fin de esta guerra y para que
busque una solución definitiva a la
graves crisis sociopolítica y
humanitaria que aqueja a Haití abogó por
el consolidamiento del proceso de paz
iniciado en Sudán del sur deploró las
víctimas del terrorismo internacional y
expresó palabras de apoyo de Consuelo
hacia las personas más vulnerables los
refugiados los presos políticos los
migrantes ningún hombre ni ninguna mujer
debe ser discriminado o pisoteado en su
dignidad estas fueron las palabras del
papa Francisco en este día de pascua la
jornada más importante del calendario 14